here are the partner of the game example
says debacle volume it looks like we
have just enough seats we were worried
about running out of room but we're
about everyone see it so any performing
tonight to this conference on the recipe
of Jews in France as Empire during world
war two before turning over to Professor
Robert Caxton we'll need some open
remarks and then as above X 1 2 3 3
Thank beautiful I want to start like
Madiba to control who are responsible as
a conference happening the bridge is for
this Robert Paxton
we could not have done this rubbish
without him he said he's been our senior
academic advisor and exceedingly
generous not only with his expertise
means ideas but does it work
is his time and and his consideration
and he's always worked with us with his
characteristic races that were very very
thankful for
from what I can tell you though
professor Watson is in theory retired
keyboards most reported that many people
we're still working full time and he
works very very hard and puts a lot of
time helping others other scholars were
doing their own research for dueling
conferences exhibits films and he's
tremendously generous of me we all the
other person who makes conference
possible is Harry Carey at Jackson and
in fact the seats bocephus compass was
planted before I even came to Columbia
when I first heard from her the
improbable story of the rabbi zalman
schneerson a Hasidic rabbi of Russian
origins who moved to France in the 1930s
and who not only lived throughout
survive throughout the war ever
disguised you know was dressed as a city
grab I with cat and full beard and long
black coat not only did he survive but
he managed to bring relief to thousands
of fellow Jews and to save dozens
by hiding them and later by smuggling
the name across the border to
Switzerland and Harry has really been
after we'll hear more about his story
tomorrow but she finally has a heart of
his confidence from the beginning to the
end or go back to Center for that to our
conference sponsors to the mind of the
voice I found a foundation and it's
President Jimmy 10 10 years also goes
well and provided input into the
conference planning we'd like to thank
the foreign school foundation the
executive vice president for arts and
sciences at Columbia is it omnia babies
and irfan sleep Adam and I'd like to
thank all the members of our advisory
board and our foundation individual and
corporate sponsors without to none of
these activities that this would be
possible finally our things go to olga
conference speakers and keep your being
here and to establish an example that's
it to all of you for
comment I I should know that there is
one change in tomorrow's agenda no bail
unfortunately they had to stay in Paris
as a very serious medical problems in
his host family and so he regrets very
much and we ever get organized that he
won't be here to share the sessions the
procession tomorrow works and provide
concluding remarks i play too is briefly
introduced as a Paxton who will then
introduce SM oz after his opening
remarks prospective needs no
introduction the special mount already
here he's asking to be free so I will be
brief he is melon professor emeritus of
social science at Columbia and come to
University in his histories of Vichy
France to be cheap as in the shoes of
course fundamentally alters historians
understanding of the nature of the Vichy
regime and its anti-jewish policies he's
also specialist at of fascism and the
author of the net the anatomy of fascism
in French as it fascism among other
books and his work has had a wide effect
beyond historical circles as well he was
other things called as an expert witness
in the trials of pochu VA and moist that
bowl and more recently in two thousand
minus a guest curator a brilliant
exhibit in your public library called
between collaboration and resistance
fresh litter I like on a business
occupation that received something like
hundred and hundred thousand visitors
wonderful exhibit he's lat lost dragon
is sort of a number of filmmakers who
have interviewed in 44 films ranging
from comes on mock Marshall it doesn't
want of the Atlantic Wall which we will
be showing here in a couple of weeks and
tonight's government you'll be
appreciating excerpts on varying fry so
it's a great honor and personal pleasure
to welcome or accident you said there's
one very homemade an hour but you
wouldn't say that
success
so
and I'm here to disarm things sort of
open up the subway conductor on
tomorrow
I think the rescue of Jews and fries
have you heard this
and before you be home and talking about
this because I heard about the subject
from books and many of you learn to die
from life
nevertheless this is my assignment to
give some background
he needs is a place in perspective
the issue of
rescue of Jews
during the German occupation
price from
it was a very special case everywhere in
your everywhere where the German army
conquered territory
Jews were in mortal danger the trash was
a special case in anyways first of all
France had the largest Jewish population
in Western Europe it's about 350,000 we
don't know exactly how many because the
French have never wanted to include
religion or ethnicity
documents but we do know that enormous
number aggression geez arrived in France
and Lionel clear dates back the French
received more Jewish immigrants
proportionally than the United States
that's not saying every
the United States notoriously received
as huge as short as possible
by making 39 foreigners refugees
particular formed about seven percent of
French population and the presence of
these strangers exaggerated three
deep-seated French anxieties one was
joblessness there was that
the immigrants or dating jobs on French
people the second was a sense of
cultural dilution the price is losing
his identity in this Walter of people
with strange accents and different
religions
and the third anxiety was addressed when
you dragged into war because many people
thought that France should make war
Hitler perhaps even a preemptive war the
rumor went around the Jewish immigrants
were pushing his campaign
the Austrians I fessor their 30s
after the first world war and its moment
asham Union any Semitism has receded
there is a great deal
hey
it was a low point wash down
ladies on the contrary there was a
resurgence of open expressions of 87 all
sorts of their respectable writers you
like Giorgio do for example this work
who were accepted as as non extreme any
way shape or form I've expressed the
view that so many immigrants so many
harvest so many refugees were a day
right security and all of these
objections and fears came to focus
around
six mile glue crisis first socialist
first Jewish Prime Minister it was
considered by
so number
and so it was a powerful backlash
the V game 40 this backlash was
supercharged into a sense
search for sleep of seat though was
bloom the Popular Front Jews
secondly the French was unique in
her was the only
that was given a pharmacist and this was
Hitler's idea wasn't something that
Marshall baytown extracted from
unwilling
it was that he wanted to do first of all
avoid and the French government go
abroad you know very well are you
thinking you claim you see that
community teen jou 1940 usually knee
which is very oral and a before Congress
territory but no one else wanted to I
next nice corsica Tunisia no no not so
fast we do that first
it was a little trouble
and furthermore if we give the French an
armistice it will be cheap to run the
place the French were running for us it
was a clever calculation if it was mad
it's not a 940 he was capable
intelligent so it was this second
originality situation there was a choice
I independent price government
we had a second out of the way I wish to
do something and I was Darren what they
were
do and so he chose to carry out its own
national revolution
to replace the despised or something
crush injuries and eat a large plazas
combination talking
from the world traditions something with
more muscle something for our core
values and within this action revolution
of course project to diminish roll jus
this probably the remaining friends
while has the country was occupied when
describing described is rebuilding the
house while extent on fire and it was
anyway
my plan was
oh yeah do is wait
warren burger chain one wouldn't
charged with making changes the
president's they made that choice so
overwhelming force of desire to get rid
of the third
they respond in kind
price and present
stronger or beautify over genius
on about the authoritarian state so the
part of this forum for this project in
Christ the Conservatives of course is
policy of discrimination and
Jews
pretty much everyone except China days
this was not something that if forced
them to do but
that point there's further comment
oh yeah
because
alysha 9040 was in fact quite the
opposite
dermatology of course evolved and in the
summer 1940 German policy
concerning Jews was to expel the jewish
population from Germany mean one day
we're looking for places to send the
Jews in Germany and as of summer and
fall of nineteen forty place a way to
send them one of the places they want to
send them Express wonderful idea all
this land
so it is very weak Marshall big-time met
Hitler and shook his hand in the ground
with card wah wah wah the 22nd over the
30 same day Gallagher's ride
load is 6504 Jews on short notice in the
railroad train sent them into France
and there was a great machine
you guys need to put an end to that
bosses but the 6,000 German Jew wouldn't
be cam shows up and we want your hand
or
and so whatever whatever didn't want to
make wouldn't want fresh to become an
a/c country as it was to go to the
fraction thought and he wanted to have a
price that would receive part of the
jewish population of germany so not it
not only do we say that Hitler didn't
force the Vichy government to adopt a
policy of Germany it was actually
contrary near Milan at the moment so we
had here to any Jewish projects french
project which was not extermination asst
though there are certain expressions of
opinion
more extreme anti-semites that were
pointed at the moment is a program of a
determination exclusion from the economy
for civil service positions intellectual
life and elves that hope is emigration
he and how else will come up these one
of the things
replaces and Christ shoes they were also
looking places to send the refugees from
the Spanish Civil War Spanish and they
were trying to eat the Mexican select
those who this we shall do is hope
somewhere else German policy was
involved point is expulsion in 1942 late
41 or divx which is extermination and
when it does the mechanisms the leechee
government is set up to diminish the
role with two friends turn out to be
extremely useful this other project was
very useful to us there's this
interlocking the gym
projects that's going on this point of
this of course is to say discussing
rescue that Jews who tries needed to be
rescued some of these French agencies
and Vanessa now I'm not going to drive
developer home instead of or even sit up
as you
s but right away I was major questions
come forward who were the rescuers ended
a negative these much-needed olives or
more like tomorrow but many just a
couple of comments who are the rescuers
I read about them unimpressed by the
extraordinary variety they come from
every class every political
us from every profession
is very difficult to generalize
any social or intellectual way there's a
magic key we make you predict might
might not
there were some ardent followers of
Marshall big time moment here tomorrow
about the vision of nice
whoa
who is a lousy Street Garda just he
adored Marshall big time when he was a
man humanitarian States and he covered
the work of his association people get
Jewish children
adjust we owe a lot of justice is a
dictionary just two may have reached a
boss with something over two thousand
names I think they're actually three
thousand French just now
this is gross underestimation because
many people honestly have you gone you
there's some other cases where the
person saved was three or four years old
and what he doesn't remember anyone's
name there are cases where people who
were responsible for saving odds never
actually appeared they a false identity
so this is 0 this is a serious
underestimation I don't know what the
factor
my people
and so we wanted in this conference to
extend our consideration beyond the
familiar territory of the just among the
nations recognized fashion more than
hoping on to look at Jewish rescuers I
was quite surprised to learn that they
are not included in there other ways was
Lorelei's abortion who are most
recognized as a moment adjust as an
issue as politics
subject accession to that
they also wanted to extend our book
Beyond metabolic process matter is very
often almost always a suit in terms of
metropolitan water to include the Empire
included in the Empire underlines the
French role of this German troops in the
Empire except briefly to nijiya between
november 1942 with a 19 23
was by march outside german control and
software that if we can should talk
about rescue in the french empire this
is strictly rescued from a she means the
DC program was was applied vigorously in
North African Sun ways even more because
it was school segregation freeze some
ways going beyond
what
so there was rescuers we got in the
Empire and we're devoting a session to
that Eric Jennings session
satella without some comedians the
Germans were president Asia
deportation became with danger and then
work they were actually rescued by some
Tunisia and neighbors Arab neighbors of
magician question and that's seven
now
the other question is what difference
did today on this animated enormous
difference the moral difference was
calculable the practical difference was
was are considerable
it's Ordinary claims in the debate
president jacques chirac has said that
three-quarters of french jews survive
because good french citizens safe and
that's not false but it's surely over
sequin because there are a number of
factors that work here
for
the fact that three-quarters of the
shoes let me try and survive and they
started low to picked it apart decide
what what factors apply this geography
there were places to hide there's the
lack of zo the administration which was
formed there were some police
it was sympathy a farce of the
population the greatest variable of
course of all was that's the investment
of energy or the Nazis chose to put the
weight of their of their force then
things happen Hungary for example early
summer 1944 where the Hungarian
government had refused to deport any
Jews and suddenly 4,000 people have
ordered in a couple of months Germans
move in by their full force they didn't
have to apply all that force France
because they have the machinery to work
for them but that's clearly the major
variable and the Italians own Italians
the protecting Jews in the occupation
zone when they leave is at number 43 the
Germans Russia
Rose other people to take
and
the rescuers are overwhelmed exaggerated
range of the date about it these numbers
only 14 taken some defenders at dca said
we must have invented something right
that's where it's counted this argument
i came up with they thought that there
are more Indians now the work that
to make a global argument a macro level
drawing conclusions
in our general figures an interesting
work I
her level Sarah gasps work as fast mom's
very interesting articles means in the
city of Los in the cut cali or they were
90 991 Jews researchers have followed
every single case and each cases
irreducibly different and but in Holland
for example people are comparing
individual cities where sawada what we
feel very different from one city to
another had to do with a view the police
have to do with presence or absence the
German forces and to some degree
rescuers it all has to be put into a
larger equation
but
of course
morally speaking Andy practically
arresting us work
he was savory barosky why you would ET
j'attend are you something all up
brilliantly I thought I heard anyone I
the people who were taken the Jews were
technical drives for taking because of
some action on the nietzsche government
and those were not taken we're not
dating
traxxas individual French citizens
that's probably a moment to meet
there was something like that in every
case is so I will even
the grace silence someone
so here are number of things that we
have with our
and I just wanted to get started I want
now to pass on to important business of
the evening which is to see some films
some of some sometime just made by
garage
there's a life as you know is a rescue
first exam he came into the world as
arrested person he was born in trauma
sista to know where his parents or
refugees in ordinary human our village
in the wild department serve this place
of refuge for very large number of fresh
tea time is shorter and we have the
revolution seeing some of the thumbs it
gets
King a documentary filmmaker
his most famous tone
nice all levels of the Spirit and it's
about someone
and proceed the dupont cambia award and
broadcast journalism for documentary
they said shoma PBS it's warmer
I think some are should not use you
suppose if we're gonna start by saying
thank you quite wonderful return yes
allies do we think
but he's he's also been working on the
phone about Harry and fri
also this year's have come coming out
called Peter Bergson clarity on the
Holocaust and there's no other this is
current work I think we're going to see
visualizers also Alaba advocate of the
history and the memory of the experience
of the refugees in chocolate and the
larger context of Holocaust founded it
runs the Shambala foundation which works
at explaining this history to young
people
so I won't
not start with the opening thing yeah
we're going to start with opening I know
that some of you know the the film which
I click for sayin but I hope you didn't
mind the reminder of that particular
episode of a rescue in Vichy France
which helps us set the scene after all
42 pipe to recall what was possible it
certainly provides a sense of where I'm
coming from literally and in other ways
one pointed Bob thank you Bob it's quite
an honor merely to be following you let
alone to hear those kind words and I
want to thank you shannon pierre larry
jackson for inviting me to participate
in this conference a few words of
introduction if I made before we proceed
with what will be of a bit of a
potpourri appropriate form is a process
for creative presentation in the French
q inary sense that I have thrown
together a bunch of ingredients
hopefully in a way that works like most
of you no doubt I'm fascinated by
history although unlike the impressive
group of historians gathered at this
conference today in tomorrow and other
historians that I've seen the audience I
grow on images and sounds an oral
testimony my own attempts to deal with
that
I'm Gary the Nazi era that won't let go
of me whoa and won't let go many of you
I'm sure I'm not alone in feeling a bit
self-conscious at sometimes sometimes
that I spend so much time looking back
and that feeling is exacerbated when
contemporary events game-changing
contemporary events pile up as they have
recently when so much is happening today
that cries out for furthered fault and
understanding moreover I remain
convinced that most people still have a
hard time letting in some of the most
challenging facts about the Holocaust
and an Aussie error in general including
that distinction between expulsion and
murder which most Americans I fear don't
really most people don't really
understand
as one of his dealing now mainly with
the American reaction to that crisis
both in the documentary which you'll see
some clips later and another documentary
called not idly by Peter Brooks an
American Hall offense I'm acutely aware
of just how difficult it is merely to
get some basic facts out when those
facts are experienced as deeply
troubling and confusing and thus I hope
you will forgive me but I cannot resist
sharing with this particular audience
the feeling that i have this past week
that we would deal with the Holocaust
may have actually been getting through
over the years in some important ways
highly relevant to us today but those
among us who have a special interest and
rescue during the Holocaust may be
getting through to which makes sense
because rescue is a subject that is
always relevant the Nazis came and went
after all rescuers are permanent feature
of the moral landscape but what I'm
getting at now is Linda
on Monday speaking about his decision to
have the US participate alongside France
and Britain and airstrikes against the
Qaddafi regime President Obama referred
again to his understanding
understandable concern that Qadhafi
edited about to report a massacre in the
rebel stronghold of Benghazi and he said
seemingly not reading from script we
can't simply stand by with empty words
when President Obama participated in his
first Washington Holocaust
commemorations present he had
underscored the importance to us of
those who had refused to stand idly by
prima Holocaust specifically and
eloquently singling out I might add the
villagers of the area bhusawal whenever
the ultimate outcome of this operation
to sleep in operation isn't it a little
reassuring that a president now realizes
after Roosevelt failed through the Nazi
massacre Jews of Europe after Clinton
failed in Rwanda that they would matter
if you remember as a president who
allowed a new massacre to occur on his
watch is it partly because the work done
by historians may be also documentary
filmmakers to some extent
that presidents and administration's
that nations will henceforth judge not
solely by what they do but also by what
they fail to do a quick additional word
now if I may about historical
documentaries such as what you're going
to see remarks that are resistible
because of the presence here of so many
stories quite frankly you historians
don't always take historical
documentaries too seriously now before I
go on let me stay for the record that
some of my best friends are historians
but I know firsthand that even when a
documentary is highly relevant and
contains much research that was not done
elsewhere it is not always cited as a
source in historical words and rare are
the books include sonographic as well if
you do graphic references is this
because documentaries don't deserve to
decide it because it is too much of a
hassle to correctly cite a film because
there are simply few documentaries
worthy of insider or put it deep
primarily because historians people of
the book after all
have a bias against this other way of
telling the stories that we all tell and
that they do not naturally recognize the
power and usefulness of the simultaneous
use of sound and images the documentary
by the way is in some ways the Jew of
motion pictures I am bus especially
gratifying to have been invited to
participate with films in this history
conference but there has also been
amazingly little thought given it seems
to me to the use of documentaries in the
classroom as the fact that students may
tend to think what is out there on
screen particularly in the shishi
elitist form of that memory is
automatically true when it's fact only
at best one particular group of
filmmakers truth as your she sees it I
hope you won't mind bought my voguing
the power of an image eventually one
involves you and then a lot to me when I
have to forgive weapons in the spirit of
using modern art ladies you're kind
enough to attend and I'll never forget
that when the lights went on after the
movie and I came up to answer questions
I happen to notice you in the audience
and you did a thumbs up gesture
forgive me but that generous and
encouraging gesture has lingered with me
more than whatever words might have been
exchanged later indeed I now remember
virtually nothing else about that this
is also the opportunity made a mention
that I set out to make weapons in the
spared 1982b injuries by Michael Maris
and Robert Paxton had just come out the
previous year in France prior to the
American magician he France infuse was
my Bible on the historical context
photo/shaam book and it didn't hurt that
the book as you didn't mention was
dedicated to the French men and women
who assisted persecuted Jews during the
Nazi occupation of France and rescuers
were not them the popular subject they
have become lastly and briefly I must
also mention how exciting it is for me
to speak and show footage here at
Columbia I grew up on the Upper West
Side I am touched it three of my oldest
friends are here this evening
with one of them as teenagers who used
to sneak into classes pottier by dr. G I
made and if I remember correctly she
never asked what we were doing here
figures out my son filmmaker david
Savage is a graduate of Columbia College
is also here today with his mom and my
wife are Rubin who has an effect it must
be said executive produced anything of
value that I turned out well the case of
our kids duh beaten Rebecca doing the
actual heavy lifting I'm also happy to
acknowledge the presence here of one of
the more illustrious members of my
family my cousin samuel pisar survivor
the death camps and long among many many
other things the chairman of ya de xem
France I'd like to mention also because
you just saw this pic from weapons a
spirit that there are at least four
people hear the word resemble during the
war rudia tell the chef Cowan Max and
Hannah leave money on to the visual
audio visuals at last I begin with some
footage that is both very old and
brand-new and that i'm showing here for
the very first time when I was making
weapons the spirit i conducted a number
of interviews that for various reasons
didn't make it into the film
some are directly connected to the
shinbone eventually find their way onto
a bonus DVD but there were three
interviews I did nearly level of better
understanding what a righteous Christian
of the Holocaust might be I cannot tell
you how foreign the very concept of a
righteous Christian was to be when I
made that film I come from a very
strongly anti religious background which
clings to me to this day and as I was
assembling three righteous Christians
for this event I realized what a large
that I owed to my den bajo on live your
mouth and jaw masuku I had forgotten
that by I ultimately didn't use their
testimony in the film having decided to
limit myself to the most part of people
most directly connect as a story the
testimony by these three people had
seeped into in shaped my understanding
of the people of your humble I hope you
find this testimony of interest please
remember that everything tonight is
billed as works in progress and a lot of
important technical improvements on
sound and picture are only done at the
very end of the process so you'll have
to bear with the limitations will you
will be seeing and the occasional
glitches are bound to crop up three
righteous Christians pleasures rafalski
brief set of clips and right after that
money about the German officer was
responsible for the area of their shell
blowing your nose it's not self tie vote
the evening is running long probably so
stay for the fried I lock the doors I'm
really not well I handle this clumsily
because part of me really think I should
why don't you show the buy price so
Frankfurt you know what I will show
pride first yet and if those if we have
time we will show the the the shelling
sequence there is a big issue some those
of you are in the field know that there
is there has been there was at one point
a lot of controversy around the German
officer who's responsible for that area
of France and I do in my film raised the
question I'm convinced I was right to do
so do you look the other way and include
some testimony that relates to that and
and makes another allegation which I
don't know quite what to make up
but I want to move on now to choose to
define if you have time we will go back
to that
and I will have more things to say about
this area fried footage after you have
seen it but I will only say now that in
addition to bear in mind that began that
much needed polishing has not had
occurred please also remember that this
will not ultimately be is short and that
I hope these clips hold together to some
extent there is much crucial material
that you will not be seen today no by
the way it is sometimes said that a
documentary is like a jigsaw puzzle but
that isn't the half of it a documentary
is like a jigsaw puzzle in which no
piece of the puzzle necessarily belongs
next to any other and in which each
piece changes its shape and appears
depending on where you put it so you are
only seeing a few of the pieces of this
puzzle that will be changing in
appearance and inform because of the
juxtapositions and now a few pieces from
that puzzle that will eventually be the
future and proudly hood very private not
say I'd like to make a few concluding
remarks and then I be really very happy
to answer your questions you have
comment on your brief comments by the
way that closing quote for very fri was
part of the blunts and emotional forward
that fried had intended for his 1945
memoir is must experience surrender
amenity but his editor random house kept
removing some of fries most heartfelt
attacks on American policies at the time
and those particular words that you just
read are in a folder that is your
Columbia cross reality at butler library
read books and manuscripts in a folder
marked in frys handwriting suppressed
material
I'd like to mention before I go on that
of course there are several people who
were willing to help you with this film
we're here today you recognize a few of
them obviously you recognize dr. Paxton
also dr. Henry Feingold this year and
also dr. Mordecai pal geo and others who
are not yet in my excerpt but will be in
the film are also year I'm very pleased
dr. glenn ferguson cook and dr. donna
ryan and shakotan one thing currently
missing from the puzzle ufs seeing is
very prized testimony about that Massey
experience his original draft of his
book by the way which I reconstructed is
much richer than what was published
there are also extraordinary plentiful
layers and I'd like to quote few a few
of those letters before early februari
1941 in a letter to his first wife
Eileen among the people comes we're
coming to my office or with who I am in
constant correspondence are not only
some of the greatest living authors
painters sculptors of Europe but also
former cabinet ministers and prime
ministers of half a dozen countries what
a strange place your is when men like
this are reduced to waiting patiently in
the anteroom of a young American of no
importance whatever
april nineteen forty one in another
letter girl i clean my work reached a
crescendo of activity writer i like
right after i got back we listened but
it has not slack adolphe a little so
that i'm at least able to breathe I
still begin at eight in the morning and
work until 11 at night sometimes up till
one I still see dozens of people every
day and that witness that displays of
every possible quality of character from
heroic despicable I still have poor
driven refugees lurking for me at my
hotel in the morning when I go out and
in the evening when I come in I still
have from six to twelve phone calls an
hour and get 25 letters a day sometimes
the refugees walk right into my bed me
without knocking or announcing himself
but the pressure is slacking not because
the situation is improving but because
more and more of our charges of being
reassured and i am at long last getting
an occasional chance to breathe it is
horrible to be glad that anybody has
been arrested but i had reached the
point of nervous exhaustion a few weeks
ago where i actually was allowed to have
a few of the most insistent and most
vociferous fights carry shrieking off if
that is in candor I don't know what is
just two more quotes in a letter to key
for I ate Albert Hirschman a few weeks
after I returned to America fry bro rope
you say you wonder what the predominant
constituent of my temper was during
those times whether enthusiasm hope
resignation or outright citizen
there was a fair measure of citizens
minute certainly I entirely agree with
you that it is necessary to have a sense
of irony if what is to handle human
miseries professionally but there was a
good deal of idealism less and less as
time went on a certain amount of ninth
day but above all yes Mary Jane above
all a common ordinariness which I
inherited my scotch ancestors it was a
tough struggle and it took all night
tough scotch character to stick it out
by the way I campus is mentioning that
we French have the best the pickiest an
untranslatable term for this last aspect
the very fry he was a nomad good
somebody could drive you nuts lastly
something fri voted staying while he was
on his way to exile in America they just
been kicked out of France with
frustration and a happiness he was
trying to convey his wife the marriage
had essentially disintegrated while he
was in France that he was no longer the
same man that he had been when he
boarded the big clipper in New York just
a year before put it this way
the roots of a plant in a pot too small
will eventually burst apopka transplant
it to a larger pump and it will soon
fill it but if you transplant it to a
pot altogether too large it will go to
root as gardeners safe and may even die
from shock I was transplanted 13 months
ago to a pot which more than once more
than one occasion I had feared that it
was too large but I didn't die in the
end I think I very nearly filled it not
entirely nearly at least I didn't die
from the shock for the sense of my
inadequacies terrified I'd be happy to
engage in a little bit of dialogue for
you yes I remember the way through this
great expert or so